there's a new wave in Hollywood - ladies
and gentlemen a wave of youth and
freshness and talent I can remember the
day when Crosby gave me that same
introduction but now here are two kids
who can live up to it to present the
sound award Miss Natalie Wood and mr.
Robert Wagner
thank you for that introduction Bob NAT
and I think you're still as youthful and
talented as you were when being first
introduced amazing isn't it hmm and you
just it's fresh we should rehearse the
readings on some of these lies
ever since the day long ago when the
screen found its voice and our movies
began to speak in the sing our sound
technicians have played a greater and
greater role in contributing to the
world's amusement today the soundtrack
is so integral a part of every
production the industry honors its
masters for their annual achievements
this year's nominees are
metro-goldwyn-mayer studios sound
department for Ben Hur 20th Century Fox
studio sound Department for Journey to
the Center of the Earth
metro-goldwyn-mayer sound department for
libel Warner Brothers Studios sound
Department for the nuns story Samuel
Goldwyn studio sound department and Tata
L sound Department for porgy and bess
Ben Hur metro-goldwyn-mayer studios
this is an award given to an entire
sound department and they all deserve it
they all worked on it there's one man I
want to thank you specially that's
recording make Sir William Stein camp
for a very excellent work